c'est une première depuis le début de la
guerre en Ukraine 108 prisonniers
ukrainiennes ont été libérés par Moscou
voici certaines d'entre elles filmaient
lors de leur retour au pays
[Musique]
elle scande gloire au héros la plus
jeune à 21 ans la plus âgée 62
volodièreski salut cette liberté
retrouvée
l'étape suivante de la libération de
notre peuple de la captivité russe a eu
lieu nous avons réussi à libérer 108
femmes ukrainiennes officielles
sergentes soldates 96 sont des soldates
12 sont décisives une libération qui est
en fait un échange contre 110 prisonnier
russe capuré par Kiev depuis des
semaines nous voici dans la région de
zapporija je veux vous féliciter pour
votre retour si vous avez des questions
n'hésitez pas je suis là pour vous aider
72 marins font partie des personnes
libérées leur unique désir revoir
rapidement leurs proches ok maman je
serai à la maison bientôt dis bonjour à
ma sœur à Tania je suis de retour
d'après les forces ukrainiennes 65000
soldats russes sont morts au front
depuis le début du conflit 10 fois moins
selon Moscou